good morning millennials ryan that's my
line sharpay we're supposed to do it
together we do everything together how
sad is that our hopes our dreams they're
all rolled up into one sharpay so you
are just riding my coattails ryan just
admit it never sharp we can do this
together
miss jarvis what do you think
i think
that the theater waits for no one so get
the [ __ ] on with it
it's fair
darb is
speaks facts no cap darvish she really
does no cap jarvis speaks facts by the
way always you are looking gorgeous ryan
thank you sharpay i got a new hat
can you give us a little um
like where ootd yeah where's all this
from bama rush style yeah so my pants i
borrowed from my husband because they're
the only thing that fits me right now um
this argyle sweater is gorgeous yes i
did so this myself it's from the costume
department right right right
and this hat amazon so cute thrifty king
yeah thrifty king everything i'm wearing
is designer um because you know our dad
likes me better recipes
i wasn't aware you guys had one and yeah
i'm just feeling so excited to be here
on the morning toast i feel like this
podcast is really going to launch my
career yeah sharpay i think you're a
star already boring
born a star you're going to do amazing
things sharp and you know what you're
going to do amazing things too behind
the scenes
i just i know you're going to be a great
producer
and a great stage hand and i'm just so
excited for this journey for us really
ryan family family over everything but i
have dreams of the spotlight sure yeah
i don't know you were at the club this
weekend put your hands up put your hand
away are you guys welcome to toast to
win
2021 that's right you've got ryan you've
got sharpay most importantly miss davis
you have jarvis jarvis is here to keep
us in check because you know sharpay i
don't want to i don't want to hurt your
feelings but you know sometimes you can
get a little carried away right and it's
important that we have the theatrical
director to keep us both in check you
know what's so comical
what
is the fact that you
say
i'm so scared you irrelevant ugly think
that you can hurt my feelings like
that's like saying you know well i know
one person who can hurt your feelings
you know i don't even need troy bolton
him and gabriella i can go run along
dancing in fields i'm going to broadway
i'm going to hollywood
how did sharpie's fabulous adventure go
sharpay it was the disney channel
original movie year of movie of the year
okay yeah that's why you bought out the
whole country club so you could spend
the summer with troy bolton don't bring
the country club into this okay you know
that was a really hard period for me
right and for you to throw it back in my
face shows you're not my true partner
that was a low sharpay how much money
did you waste sunny would never have
done this to share employees sonny would
never have done this to share employ the
entire wildcats just so troy would talk
to you yeah
that is something i don't think it's
pathetic actually it's oddly reminiscent
of you know really strong female
heroines in in i can't even talk
in some of my favorite films and plays
that's sorry i'm such a method actor
that i just kind of channeled juliet of
romeo and juliet you would know nothing
about that ryan would you i would know i
think he would thank you now i don't
think you would know what it's really
like to put yourself out there in a real
way i do because kelsey and i have
something special which is why i
borrowed her
where is kelsey she's working on
something new for trying every island
not for you yeah no uh i'll go see to
that yeah no it's some for best work um
happy halloween right happy halloween
thank you for being here thank you for
having me i can't lie i can't recall an
episode of the morning toast halloween
or otherwise where i've ever been so
uncomfortable in an outfit like i've
never obviously sweating you look
incredible
my wig is like sliding back i'm so hot
sharpay who
evans
you guys like this wig is so tired like
i'm so hot no you look so good blonde is
your color you think yeah i think so too
and those glasses gucci yeah via amazon
for amazon you know what i saw people i
ordered this all a while ago but i saw
people on tick tock who like had dressed
up as sharpay not obviously as good as
awesome not as in character um and
everyone got these glasses because when
you search pink glasses on amazon it's
the first to come up and they're so
sharp they really are like i feel like
all i needed was the sunglasses
everything else my bow it's just an
accoutrement yeah and the wig of course
yeah the wig that's for a toddler it's
like sliding off my head speaking of
wigs hey darmus hello your hair's
looking a little unkempt it says
everything okay at home i had a wild
night with coach bolton last night
is everything okay at home with mr
darmo's
no
there is no mister there is no mr dobbs
not anymore yeah his name is mr bolton
oh yeah i can't have husbands so um
my husband davis uh why am i british now
um when are the spring musical uh
auditions
um auditions will be in the month of
march okay callbacks will be in april
and you will not be getting one
that's not very darkest of you actually
yes it is all's equal in the theater
everyone gets a callback well no they
don't not everyone gets everyone's an
audition yeah but everyone like me gets
a call back
because you're the only one who tries
out usually except for troy and
gabriella what should we do this year
bro for the musical no for the audition
i think we should do one of our classics
meet you a bop to the top or
bop to the top
i'm feeling top to the top yeah i'm kind
of feeling that too it's kind of like a
dangerous choice but i think rehearse
yeah okay
jarvis close yours yeah we don't want to
spoil it for you
i believe in dreaming
shooting for the stars
baby to be number one you've got to
raise the bar
the ladder of success
shake our tails off every day
wrong line ryan
competition throw them all away
blow them all away
yeah we're gonna pop up
to the top slip and slide and ride that
rhythm jump jump jump
don't
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's really good we need to work on
that one yeah i think you really need to
work on like that whole thing i think i
held it down i didn't wouldn't agree
i think you're a little rough around the
edges yeah you know i think my i think
you had a wild weekend it's affecting
your voice i think my glasses are um
starting to fog up for how hot it is
under my wig you could take your glasses
off we're all friends here sharpay no i
overslept and i really didn't have a lot
of time to do my best to play makeup
i tried to put like pink eyeshadow on my
it looks like um
i got pushed
maybe i mean maybe somebody had enough
of sharp [ __ ] like and they finally
punched honestly it looks good you look
great okay but like the glasses aren't
bothering me the wig is the sharpie
could never no sharpie could never
oh my god you know being sure pays a lot
of work i have a lot of respect for
ashley tisdale yeah
no she gives it all every single day she
does and you know while i'm here i would
just like to show like sharpay in 2021
has been cancelled sufficiently well she
was like canceled in 2008 then she was
resurrected briefly justice for sharpay
but now she's been thoroughly cancelled
once again like
yeah so i'm now here as kind of the um
the grown-up version of sharpay who's
had her tweets exposed who's had her old
high school bullying activities exposed
on a tick tock
so i'm just here as like a person who
is eating pot humble pie
and i'm here to issue an apology it's a
screenshot on my notes app it's pink
it's scented
and i just want to say
i'm you know the person i was when i was
a teenager is not currently who i am now
and who are you now sharpay i'm a
philanthropist
i'm a lover of
animals and humans i'm a thespian
i love the theater i love art i love
culture um i don't know i've just kind
of grown up over the last couple years
and i think you guys are gonna be really
excited for the sharpie that you're
gonna see here today that's beautiful
shut up ryan
shut up seriously like it's enough ready
i just i wouldn't support you i want to
support you shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up you're right i talk too
much i completely agree
okay well we have a great show for you
today per usual we'll be in and out of
character you never know when sharpay's
hammer is going to come down on ryan
your hat like it's too much i mean i
think it's so fabulous oh everyone's
gonna be wearing it next season for sure
yeah
show us your best jazz hands
you guys if you're listening today's a
podcast i highly recommend obviously
coming over to youtube we're in full
costume and it's just ween and we're
gonna do a regular episode obviously but
we just really can't be helped as
thespians ourselves if the ryan sharpay
and darvish just kind of ooze out of us
yeah because it's who we are at our core
and it's what happens you know it is
what happens it's worth mentioning that
jackie and i did fight over who when i
fight i was gonna ask how you guys
decided we both wanted ryan we both
wanted to be right even though you would
think that like sharpay is the more
desirable character i think that ryan's
a bit more nuanced and more dynamic and
easy to like get into victim mentality
like
nobody wants to be like the big bully
especially me you have a really easy
right that's what i'm saying like now
everyone who thinks i'm mean to like you
and ben is just going to be like look
she was so good at sharpay so obviously
i didn't want to do this so we actually
flipped a coin because we we not in
there that was fair neither of us would
back down on it and i just really didn't
want to be like big pregnant sharpay
like big dope and i understand pink yeah
i do understand that so i don't call me
i'm a big jump in pink yes silly sharpe
okay that is sharp i'm just saying i
just feel really comfortable in this
outfit i think it's more maternity
friendly i agree i agree and so i'm just
like living my best life literally call
me jazz hands
jazz square um so i also feel weird that
we're like
swapped seats yes but just jarvis and i
are just
kind of a team you know you always want
to stick close to darby so you can
manipulate her
i'm a sneaky brown-noser with a
not-so-hidden agenda
it's true um so now that i'm sitting
here like should i do the crunch
oh do you want to get into everything do
you have anything else to talk about no
i mean just i had a nice evening with
kelsey last night when we caught up on
real housewives and then she went home
to work on hershey and then you did a
little jam sesh
yeah we did we're always just jamming
you can't put the jam in the jar no but
like when i think about like some of the
time you spend with kelsey like it does
make me sad why because i'm just out
here living a fabulous life on our
father's restaurant piece dime and i'm
just you know what i did last night i
went to movie premiere and i actually
saw zac efron do you remember him he
went to our high school troy yeah um
he's in this new film and he was
obviously so excited to see me it was
really um kind of like a beautiful
moment full circle he obviously saw the
growth in me you know i mean i really
get to talk to him because he pretended
he didn't see me but i um
i felt this like spiritual connection to
him that's good that's good that no
matter how much like you grow and about
like you're still delusional
yeah like that's kind of like part of my
brand yeah that's your hallmark you know
i'm really excited to be on this podcast
because i really feel like ryan you and
i should really start um like working on
our social media you know okay i think
we can get discovered that way or at
least i can yeah no i have some really
good ideas and plans i think people
would want to hear from me and you know
my take on how i you know live my
lifestyle sure ryan like how i got this
sweater yeah no it's and i have other
sweaters too we believe it
are gonna give that sweater to zach when
you're done no i'm gonna give it to you
i would wear that oh yeah like that's
what the kids are wearing like emma
chamberlain's yeah
the hat i'm keeping obviously no the hat
goes in the toast hall of fame yeah no
this hat has changed my life no i know
sometimes you put on a piece of clothing
that like literally changes the dna
inside of the person like yeah it gives
you a whole new perspective is there
anything today that's changing your dna
i guess these glasses a little bit but
honestly i know i'm not having the same
sort of like moment as you are but you
know what ryan needs a moment so
it's fine jarvis are you
feeling personally attached to your hair
i mean of course look at my look at my
thoughts you look so good you do thank
you so much thank you for my kimono
yeah i'm gonna need that back yeah no i
don't want it
no i'm just jarvis is a savage i don't
know what you expected jarvis is a
savage
i get a lot of compliments on that no i
know it just looks different like when
you're not wearing it on a beach that's
true that's true yeah yeah but when
you're running in the theater everything
sparkles right garbage right that's
right oh so what does this spring
musical you didn't tell us um you know
we're still ideating a lot okay okay i
heard it's a darby's original jarvis has
become lazy
she's really kind of slipping up in here
i think we're gonna do dear evan hansen
sounds like ryan's gonna shine oh my god
there's no female lead in tara and
hansen no no you'll be what's her name
the sister laura
she's played by a girl named laura but i
think wait jarvis how do i look
i'm ready oh she has her cast on all
right let's hear it this is an
opportunity for ryan let's hear it i
could i could help you workshop you know
i'll let you have this one
on the outside always looking in will i
ever be more than i've always been cause
i'm tap tap shut up sharp hi this is my
moment listen
waving through a window oh
can anybody see hey is anybody waving
back at me
oh
waiting
shut up waiting
hey
gorgeous right what do you think darvis
i think it's good i think i'm a shoe
unless troy tries out he'll really give
me a run for my money i don't know i
purposely moved the school decathlon the
basketball team
qualifying game the great finish bake
off and all the other extracurricular
activities to the same time as auditions
so no person could be in two place at
once right and i did that for you
[Laughter]
okay here's the plan for today's show
you guys we got the fast five
um we've got some tv recap last night
was the finale of potomac um housewives
and then also a new episode of salt lake
city housewives which was both just like
may
um big man big map but there's lots of
news lots of things we have a lot to
discuss so you get the new bravo news
yes okay so let's jump right in
to the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
gorgeous
sharpay adds that wig's not gonna pay
for itself sorry sorry i got so
distracted by my wig it's so itchy
today's episode
is brought to you by legacy box
send your legacy box fill it with old
home videos and pictures and legacy box
will do the rest they'll digitize your
moments onto a thumb drive the cloud or
a dvd it's like magic
so each item that you sent them will be
hand digitized by their team of over 200
trained technicians and it's all done
right here in the usa they've been an
industry leader in professionally
digitizing family member memories for
over a decade their exclusive barcoded
online tracking system provides up to 12
email updates along the way and each kit
includes everything you need to safely
pack and send your recorded moments
legacy box is giving our listeners early
access to the black friday sale
everyone's always waiting for legacy box
sales here's one visit legacybox.com
toast to unlock an exclusive discount
for black friday that's
legacybox.comtoast for the best deal of
the year
legacybox.com don't miss it they
like uh people are always messaging me
for the sale and you always miss it so
legacybox.com
for the black friday sale i love legacy
box because we get to see all of our
memories you know when we were in the
theater growing up mom and dad recorded
everything yeah for me that's so nice i
think they probably thought like when i
was a kid i was such a star that i'd
someday end up you know the grammy
museum or the rock and roll hall of fame
something like that and they just wanted
to preserve
all of my things which i thought was
really cool of them they're so smart
like that yeah and mine too yeah no i
think they have a bunch of your hats in
a box somewhere in the attic
i hope that flood in 97 didn't get to
them
okay first story you guys big news i'm
i'm still thinking like quaking thinking
about it we need to discuss the season
is quaking the theater is quaking kim
kardashian and pete davidson holding
hands at not scary farm they went on
some rides together first of all they
were just like together hanging out
which is just weird they were part of
big group obviously so it wasn't like a
one-on-one date but obviously like
there's okay so like there was just like
the group photo that was at first
shocking then they sat next to each
other on the ride like okay they held
hands and then the picture okay how they
got people magazine got that picture
that's like taken on the ride i wonder
how much they paid the operator for that
yeah
they're holding hands they look so cute
and
is there any chance in hell that they
are
a romantic item yeah i mean
like every like pg6 is saying they're
just friends everyone is saying they're
just friends i mean they might just be
friends right now but it's obviously
like step like a stepping stone no yeah
i just feel like two like uh uh of age
single people don't right hands on a
roller coaster who just kissed on tv
right you don't have hands on a roller
coaster unless like there's
the beginning of feelings no there's
definitely something going on i don't
know if it's gonna last forever i think
this is probably just like kim's you
know flinging back into single life but
i think they're definitely going to bone
like and spend some time together i'm
obsessed i never
i never would have put these two
together i'm obsessed like i'm so
obsessed for kim because it like he's a
funny guy she'll have fun obviously he's
doing something right with his life he
literally dates the most prestigious
women in town
and i'm obsessed for pete because it's
like also you have to remember like he
was engaged to ariana grande like if you
really can't go up from there in life
you know what but i don't really feel
like he's gone down at all no he hasn't
but like
now he's dating
no and like now it's just like let's
let's all take a step back okay kim we
have to look at pete davidson who has
now we think dated kim kardashian ariana
grande kate beckinsale phoebe what was
her name oh phoebe
margaret quality right uh kaya gerber
ever or no i just got her confused with
margaret quality like they're so similar
that's a good that's an interesting i
feel like briefly but i could be
confusing my skinny brunettes okay so
we have this man
who's dated all these women like
literally the most sought-after gorgeous
rich bachelorettes in the world and pete
is just like this funny guy from staten
island like it's so
it's so crazy to me first of all i don't
know anyone who's ever dated that many
eligible women in such a short period of
time and someone who's just so like he's
not the um he's not george clooney like
he's on a tv show he's a stand-up comic
he's from staten island he still lives
in his mom's house like it's
honestly mind-boggling it boggles the
mind no it's an amazing story
a true uh
it's a hero story yeah it's a it's a
happy a happy ending yeah no you love to
see it i mean kim is the most eligible
bachelorette in the world
and
i'm really really here for this i hope
that it's something i mean or at the
very least that they're going into
business together because i would love
to see what these two could cook up yeah
that's true i mean maybe they're gonna
be in a movie together and like she's
helping him he's helping her like be
funny like learn how to
block cameras but that's like when you
are like working on a project with your
crush
and you're like we should go to not
scary farm to work on the project that's
literally what happened to you and
kelsey like you tricked her to come to
your house to see like your collection
of keyboards yeah
and she brought her sheet music and just
plots right and it was on from there so
like that's why i feel
as though even though it might not be
something yet for these two they could
be on the road to love like me and
kelsey have found we're literally
on our way yeah i can't believe it by
the way when i saw these pictures it was
i didn't know what i was looking at and
it was so shocking that it actually took
me some sometimes you understand
okay kim pete who cares wait they kiss
wait they're both single wait they're
both like looking wait they're holding
hands
right
it's a journey to get to the final
conclusion that like these two might
actually end up like
an item not forever i don't think but
like it'll be a fun little thing that
kim did on the way to her next
relationship mr right now yes yes
hello what do you think counts
darbus counselor darvis and this darbus
is the ultimate counselor wait that's a
great question mr arborist what do you
do in the summers
she writes the summer's off yeah yeah i
know so you don't volunteer at a theater
camp or anything i know they go to um
some summer camps they bring me in as
like a you know guest of a liaison yeah
um but besides that i really it's where
i can just debrief from the craziness of
you [ __ ] and do darbist tings yeah
darwistick what do darba's tings and
tails dart was tangs and tail i smoke a
lot of weeds first is a pothead for sure
jarvis definitely like is a like
son's topless yeah for sure no she does
that like outro vagina i like like
swinger parties you know
is there a mr dermis no no you killed
him the theater is your husband theater
is mr dallas would you say that the
theater came between mr and mrs jarvis
there was never a mr darwin oh there was
never no theater was in the way oh got
it okay
she's married to her work i'm sorry to
have offended you it was starbucks it's
okay you know i'm probably going to end
up being the next mrs jarvis
how's your mr evans going
sharpay those who can't do teach never
forget
excuse me right am i catching a [ __ ]
attitude from you [ __ ]
is that is that wait did i hear a
[ __ ] attitude shut the [ __ ] up brian
go back to your sheet music
let me go back to the auditorium okay
sure pay i thought you've changed i have
someone's gonna make a tick tock
exposing you for this behavior we're
being recorded you know what
villain mentality over here okay
this is the villa like you know we need
a villain origin story about char pay
like how did she get this way yeah
like let's do like the year before
gabriella and troy transferred to
yeah what was sharpay going through
right and i'm sure sharpay had to like
beat out some seniors when she like the
year before who were like putting her
down saying sharpay you're not good
enough but then you know you live long
enough and the you you become the
villain and i think that's what happened
to sharpay i think so too and then
what's going on at the evan's home she
could have like used her position of
power in the theater for good raise up
other voices within the theater and
instead she put them down no of course
because you want to know why a star is a
star and a star will rise and she has
rise
she has racism sorry i didn't want to
use the wrong tense and i'm this jar and
i just think it's time everyone on this
[ __ ] couch got on board well i'm on a
different couch so but i'm already on
board you know i'm team sharpay choo
choo that's right ryan
and you know what for that small
compliment you can be the stage manager
in my next production thanks sharpay
it's my family streamed i know you could
bring that little kelsey to have her
write me a stellar ballad for the second
act kelsey like is knocked down for you
no it really comes between our
relationship not to make it about me no
and i think we should talk about how
this relationship you found yourself and
while i am super super happy for you
it's definitely become toxic for our
family we've all kind of spoken about it
and we don't think kelsey's the right
fit i mean i know mom and dad really
like her so it's really just you no i
actually spoke to mom and dad rest in
peace um
and they were basically just saying how
they think this is not my words it's
theirs that kelsey's taking advantage of
you she doesn't actually like you and
she's using you for your money and
connections as a songwriter
well at least she's using me
okay you know at least someone wants to
hang out with me
i'm
okay are you ready for our next story
yeah big news announced this morning a
new bravo real housewives franchise is
coming in 2022 and it's the real
housewives of
dubai
bravo is further expanding the real
housewives franchise with its first
international locale officially
greenlighting the real houses of dubai
now that was a little confusing because
there are other real housewives like
melbourne
but those are by different production
companies like they kind of like license
out the name though they don't answer
they don't err on american bravo and
like bravo doesn't claim them no they
don't it's actually really weird i don't
really get how that whole thing works it
is really weird this is not that no this
is full andy cohen approved this is full
any kona crude airing on bravo you know
9 8 central
so andy said in a press release
everything's bigger in dubai and i
couldn't be more excited to launch
bravo's first international housewives
series in a city i've been fascinated by
for years with an outstanding group of
friends as our guides caroline stanberry
is rumored to be heavily involved well
that was my next thing like she must be
involved and
that is so exciting to hear the cast has
not been revealed yet but if they're
revolving around caroline like i'm so in
no and you know what like what do i
always say is required for a housewife
to be successful money and there's
literally no shortage of money in dubai
and i actually think this is a great
selection i think it'll be so
interesting i mean i think a lot of
people wonder about like what it's like
in dubai like from bravo's perspective
we've seen glimpses of it like on the
real housewives of beverly hills but to
live there must be so interesting you
have to be so rich and i actually cannot
wait to see who they choose i can't wait
to see all the homes the cars the bags i
think it's going to be fabulous i give
us an a-plus but you know what i do
think it's now becoming like
i think they need to like cancel another
oh i guess they did just cancel dallas
yeah cause like it's too much and not
all of them are so good yeah that like
in order for me to keep being like a
full-time fan they gotta whittle it down
they gotta come to that yeah and that
was i guess them at in dallas even
though i think there are other
franchises that deserve to go before
dallas but it's easy to cut off dallas
when it's not an og franchise like
people are so attached to new york and
oc even though they both deserve to be
permanently canceled yeah i agree with
everything and i think dubai is going to
be really great and
we do it's like so crazy for caroline
stanberry like she was ladies of london
she moved to dubai they stopped the show
because there's no ladies in london
without caroline it did get really bad
and then no it was always good it would
like never had time to get bad and now
like i'm sure this is happening in large
part because of her 100 and also when
they announced yesterday that like you
know andy was going to be announcing a
new franchise and i was like racking my
brain trying to think about what it
could be
because i was just thinking u.s but now
right opens up the whole world to real
housewives franchises i mean the real
housewives of paris like that would be
sick
um yeah i think in
in new york i mean in america the only
thing that
would still be good
is the real housewives of nashville
yeah with like you know
country singers wise yes like britney
aldean and like uh rayleigh and like
well she's a singer so she's too busy
but like yes singers and wives yes i
agree gwen stefani could be on it i
agree i don't think they live in
oklahoma totally i don't think that
they'll do it like i don't mean i don't
think the women will do it i don't think
they want to open up their lives like no
and they're so rich like they don't need
it and they're so famous in their own
circles like they don't need the fame or
the money which is why it would be good
yeah agreed well that's like some very
exciting bravo news for all of us yeah
and did you see i sent you something
last night from like a bravo fan page
they think they found who have the new
uh friend of beverly hills is yeah i
mean she was just at dinner so she could
just be like invited but she had she had
a house sell for 87 million dollars so
that's always good yeah i'm just like
not on that level of fandom of like you
know exploring who showed up to a meal
oh and for beverly hills i think i am oh
no but i'm glad to see that enthusiasm
from you sharpay it's nice to be
passionate about things ryan you should
try it sometime i am passionate about a
lot about something besides your hats
and kelsey and kelsey and your best wow
with the knife jarvis with the night in
the library no in the auditorium
oh you don't like the word auditorium no
no that's so provincial
it does dole down what she does yeah she
doesn't like to be reminded she's in a
house in a school right like literally
darvis you're such a thespian and like
you literally spent all your time in a
sweaty auditorium that they also use for
the science to catholic i have tenure so
oh
you should take a sabbatical soon
darby's you work too hard okay do you
want to travel darvis where do you want
to go i would love to go to the theater
capital of the world broadway new york
i was going to say like [ __ ] kansas
oh yeah i've heard that the the theater
scene in wichita is handed unparalleled
me too so darvish
no sorry no it's okay okay are you ready
for our next story
yeah yeah
okay because alec baldwin is speaking
out about the fatal shooting of helena
hutchins on the rust set i'm sure a lot
of you guys have seen this video by now
and if you haven't please go watch it
because we're just going to talk about
the body language over the vibes of this
video so
alec and
hillary hillary hillary hillary are in
vermont and paparazzi are like staking
them out and so they finally they
stopped in the middle of the road to
like answer some questions and
everything about it was off now first of
all i think most noticeably was like
that hillary was trying to make it about
herself and that really rubbed people
the wrong way no it rubbed alec the
wrong way like alec was
not letting her make it about herself
for me i thought alec was
unhinged i think the whole i think the
concept of these two people stopping in
the middle of the road to talk to
paparazzi about the death of a young
woman is so inappropriate and i think
like they the way that they're acting is
like literally so disrespectful to her
family yeah and i when i saw the video
i'm like there's no way this is real
like i can't believe they actually got
out and talked to paparazzi about this
woman like
and i get i think he's so desperate to
clear his name because like people
already hated him he wasn't like known
for being the best guy before this and i
think that like he's worried that people
will think that like he was responsible
and i get that for sure but i think you
have to act with respect and
like dignity towards the person who is
like it's a legal matter so like shut up
yeah no one's expecting you to stop on
the side of the road and talk to the
paparazzi if you want to keep walking
with your head down that's that would be
understandable for all of us that's
something that like a youtuber does so i
thought like them speaking about the
case at hand was odd and i thought the
way that he spoke to her was like so
rude but she was being annoying as i
don't know but like still there's a
million cameras it's not as if you don't
know that you're being watching like
you're gonna yell at your wife no
obviously if you're yelling at your wife
like that in public you're yelling at
her worse in the house and if you're
yelling at her not just in public in
front of cameras right yeah like it was
so like stopping her away like a fly a
body language expert could literally do
like a dissertation on that video be a
body language amateur and you could sum
this up so i thought that like she was
being so annoying because it's obviously
not about you and she just like kept
trying to get in frame like every time
the camera moved she would move too yeah
um and the way alec was so dismissive
and rude to her like you don't talk to
your wife like that like
there's so much to unpack from this
video and that's just starting
conceptually the fact that they even
participated in this video is so
disgraceful to me and i think even if
they had said ever even if they struck
the right tone and said everything's
right i would have said you know what
that's still weird that they're talking
to the paparazzi on the side of the road
when nobody expects to hear from them
right now it's an ongoing criminal
matter but
the content of the video and what was so
surprising to me is like most of the
commentary i saw was just about like
making fun of hilaria which yes there
that's there for sure but likes don't
insult my intelligence by calling her
hilarious seriously
making fun of him hillary
um
which is definitely an element to the
video but like
alex behavior
is so crazy no you know what he's
unhinged and he's obviously been through
a traumatic event so i'm here to give
him a little bit of grace but i'm just
increasing and we spoke about this on
the podcast on friday how he's like
tweeting out articles about i just think
his behavior has been so
disrespectful and so like insane
since this incident and i just would
expect more out of like a major
celebrity honestly yeah with the
publicists through like scandals before
like right
exactly
just know what to do yeah yeah so that
video was honestly like the most
shocking thing i've ever seen in my life
no for a multitude of reasons i get
through the whole thing it's painful i
know the way he keeps walking away from
her to get her out of the camera frame
and she keeps walking back into the
frame and he yells at her like shoves
her away it is
truly
a marriage story like it's horrible yeah
and they're both filming and everyone
was like why were they filming it so
that like their words wouldn't get taken
out of context if someone like edited
that that makes sense but
it's like no one
just let it play out right like you guys
are digging your own grave you don't
need someone else to like edit a video
to make you look bad you already look
and it's not about things that you're
saying it's like how you're saying it no
they're so [ __ ] toxic like it's crazy
yeah yeah okay you ready to move on to
our next story if it's brought to you by
overland a family-owned heritage brand
that puts comfort and quality first for
nearly 50 years they offer outerwear
accessories and home decor made from
sustainable natural fibers like
sheepskin leather and wool there they
use expert craftsmanship to pair the
highest quality merino sheepskin with
supportive memory foam midsoles in order
to make slippers that make that feel
better and wear better for longer i've
been wearing those um overland ones
around the house i was talking about
them on the podcast or was that the
patreon yeah the patreon um they're the
best slippers i own they're so
comfortable they're real like indoor
shoes but they have such good souls like
i wear them sometimes outside to walk
theo um
they're well made they're comfier than
you can imagine and everyone needs a
pair of slippers also like it's november
1st i know you probably forgot because
we're in costume but like holiday season
the snow season is upon us and like if
you're cultivated by a cultivating vibe
being a chilly lighting candles you need
a really good pair of slippers so check
out overland they offer 100 satisfaction
guarantee and their commitment to
customer service is exceptional don't
wait another day to slip into something
way more comfortable get the highest
quality sheepskin slippers on the market
at overland.com toast you'll get free
shipping and free returns and we
recommend you go today because the
slippers are so beloved they've been
known to sell out that's overland.com
toast overland.com toast
great okay our next story celebrity
halloween 2021 um the costumes came out
where let's talk about celeb costumes
and then also like what everybody else
was wearing this year the most popular
costume obviously being
kravis and you know what like since it
was so popular i saw so many people who
did it so good but like if you just bare
minimum did it like i'm talking about
like celebrities influencers like if you
just did the bare minimum like honestly
it was like kind of a terrible costume
but like do you see betty drama of
course like that is
understanding the assignment like
literally i couldn't tell who was megan
and who was benny drama like yeah it was
so sickeningly done and honestly after i
saw his costume anyone else who did mgk
or tr or kravis like meh but courtney
had reposted a lot of people who were
them and there were a lot of like
non-famous people who dressed up yeah
and it was very much like the costume
that everybody of the year was doing and
so many people did it so good
yeah
so
that's probably most popular also mgk
and megan and megan kelly were a very
popular and also like the four of them
together yeah it was a popular costume
and then courtney travis themselves the
king and queen of halloween this year
dressed out as
sid vicious and nancy spungen and they
also dressed as a movie
did you see the picture on danny
michelle's instagram yeah but i don't
know i didn't know any of the excuse me
references i didn't know the reference
but then i saw that actually like the
movie has a connection to shauna
you're lying apparently like that's like
their movie that was like the first
dance at their wedding was like this
song their daughter alabama is like
named after that movie it's like a big
movie and they're right that's really
[ __ ] weird yeah
i think like that's what did you see
that like on instagram no like yeah in
the tabloids that's really bizarre yeah
i mean she's already having like a bad
couple weeks
yeah this might
be the knife the nail in the coffin
right after being eliminated from
dancing with the stars like that's not
what you want to see no that's sharna
burgess i was just like what the [ __ ] we
get confused here at shanna mochler and
sharna burgess because they're both a
part of the me gun kelly because yeah
sharna is married dating brian who was
married to me gun and shanna was married
to travis so it's very confusing because
they both have the same name and they're
both a part of the same foursome it's
really weird it is really confusing so
let's talk about favorite celebrity
halloween costumes um and also a very
successfully done one was joe and sophie
turner were
have you ever seen isabella and paulo
yeah and so they had another girl with
them who was i think isabella but i
didn't see anyone being the sneaky brown
nose or where they hid an agenda well
that's where you come in yeah
um and hillary duff commented
quaking so what were some of your
favorite costumes this year so by the
way we have a new patreon episode up we
just like shot the [ __ ] forever um oh
yeah we did a q a yesterday but we also
just went i'm talking about halloween
the whole time who knew there was so
much to say about all the different you
know holiday traditions and i give my
dissertation on why i think halloween is
a fat phobic holiday
and a lot of people really just kind of
rallied around me just one but i'm happy
for you one person just one i agree but
like no one's gonna tell that's all you
need because one is one is all you need
to start a movement i see you
um what oh so favorite halloween
costumes i said this on the patreon i
thought that lil na's x dressing as the
guy from nc classified was hilarious
niche reference i thought it was great i
loved it yeah yeah snatcher i can't
think of one celebrity right now lizzo
did baby yoda she looked really cute a
lot so the popular costumes were like
squid games also yeah um queens gambit
ryan seacrest oh honestly my number one
was kikinan agreed agreed she she is
onya is annie taylor joy and she
literally like her [ __ ] chest purse
yeah everything can you know
the chest headband yeah and if you're
gonna do queen's gambit like it has to
be premium because beth harmon is such a
premium girly yeah but also ryan
seacrest and kelly both dressed up as
queen's gambit and they actually did a
pretty good job yeah i'll show you a
picture um and i agree kitts was
kids was really good at someone who was
just like home all weekend watching the
costumes come in it was really fun a lot
of people were ted lasso yes yeah
um which
we don't watch i just feel like a lot of
people what they do for halloween is
like especially like influencers and
celebrities like they do the most basic
outfit but because they have money they
throw money at the problem and it's like
crazy hair crazy makeup and they just do
like a devil to the nth degree yeah yeah
get creative no or they'll do like a
really niche pop culture reference and
post like an instagram side by side of
like what they're supposed to be and i
just think if you have to post a side by
side if you have to explain and i didn't
know before it's not a good costume yeah
and also what a lot of people did
especially this year is like get dressed
up do like a full blown photo shoot
sketch tick-tock
haley bieber was um written britney
spears she looked just like her yes she
looked really great and she like did all
these different looks it's like she did
these photo shoots i think she went
trick-or-treating in the outfits like no
i think she probably did the photo shoot
like a month ago no it's like halloween
is just as much for instagram as it is
for yeah like everything and you know
kylie was very low-key she just posted
she like dressed as a cat and she just
went trick-or-treating
i bet trick-or-treating in hidden hills
is like so sickening you definitely get
like a whole ass you get like ipads like
a cake yeah at one house yeah a box of
krispy kreme and another and it's just
like every house you go to is another
like billionaire either mega star like
tech muggle yeah great place to network
yeah you know they can definitely give
out full-sized candy bars like not
obviously not ew do you think that
there's any toaster who lives in hidden
hills who would like invite us to her
home not invite us to your home but is
listening and saying good luck yeah and
if you do send us a message let us know
what it's like i won't share your name
i'm so curious let us know what they
give out on halloween yeah definitely
full size i feel like they just give
away big bags you know like um they
don't even open the from the grocery
store everyone gets like their own
makeup it's like you know specialty
items from dylan's candy bar like
they're artisanal yeah they're ordering
from gold belly we know that kourtney
kardashian is giving out sugar free
candy organic always do you have to
remember that episode it's a candyland
party yeah yes yes so she's giving out
sugar travis is also like sugar-free
gluten-free i don't think so i think he
is now i do think that there are some
potato on livestock on lifestyle choices
i don't know
i don't think they've had to make hard
decisions between the two of them have
you and kelsey had to make any hard
decisions well yeah because kelsey's
gluten-free and i just don't understand
like why she would cut that out of her
life trouble in paradise but i'm
supportive because that's me i've
learned how to be supported from being
your brother
that felt like an insult
i'm constantly supporting you
yeah yeah i guess you could say that
i'm in a lofty dream not matter never
going to come when you're scheming
behind my back with all the nerds from
the drama department and the basketball
team sometimes you need to learn
something the hard way sharpay and me
contributing to their scheme made you
learn it faster quicker and i think more
painlessly you're welcome i don't really
think that was the case i think you were
trying to impress kelsey and or corbin
blue also name i can't remember
um
but also between you and me and
gabriella was like all over me that
summer i completely agree i heard all
about it am i you did ms darvis wasn't
in the second movie
she just let us out what is disgrace oh
summer
summer they should have invited darvis
to the talent show and to be the
director of like the talent that was
amazing and she's the best character she
got no love
i know but she does but she got all the
love um during high school musical three
yeah when when um
troy was having his mental breakdown you
know walking on walls in high school oh
yeah walking on walls yeah yeah so like
gabriella was coming for me i was like
troy who
yes sure ryan
um
call me gabs if things don't work out
with kelsey
who knows no did you hear what are we
living in like a post high school um
ryan and sharpay or like a current we're
living like
high school musical three has wrapped
okay and like we're like stuck like in
the society we're stuck in a time warp
okay okay i'm just like not sure like am
i living in an apartment in new york
going for auditions you're not 30 years
old sharp eggs oh okay i'm not 30. okay
sharpay if they're older than you
claudia okay i just thought you were
like trying to call me 30. no no okay no
no no no no no no no
what were you going to say nothing i was
worried about living in an apartment in
new york oh yeah so i'm like is sharpay
like living in a 2021 apartment like
trying to go on auditions for broadway
or
she just left graduation do you think
that's where sharpay would she just left
graduation for this show but do you
think that's where sharp hey would be
now how many years really is she's
actually 30 because when we were she was
older than me high school musical three
came out in 2008. i remember she
graduated high school in 2008. right
that person is 30. october 24th 2008.
okay all right
darby steel trap um
okay so she's like a little over 30
actually
uh i'm 28 i graduated high school in
2010. i'm a little young for my age
though but yeah you are right three
months okay so it's
she's saturday she just celebrated her
30th birthday [ __ ] it really sad so it's
like 13 years
post not 13. like
sure okay whatever it's third i'm 30.
accept it
so i'm a 30 year old sharpay i bet
probably after high school i moved to
new york
did the new york thing did the new york
thing like maybe got like one
job on like an off-broadway show in the
chorus line like um and then i'm like so
sorry to tell you but she went to
university of albuquerque oh in sharpay
ever after no no at the end of high
school musical theory yeah she she
stayed on at the theater department at
east high and then also went to
university of albuquerque because ryan
was one who got the scholarship to
juilliard
once again taking things from me um yeah
so i guess like she probably would now
really be like the next miss darvis
that's like the whole cycle pray for the
campers no literally but she's grown and
she's changed i'm sure miss starbucks
you know when she was
25 wasn't like a gem
i'm sure she was jarvis has been an old
soul from the job that's true so wise
always constantly
okay are you ready
for our already and final story i got
this ryan why don't you just uh manage
the stage it's the final story
shut up ryan
is my life
those pipes damn girl
thanks ryan
you know we should really
use our powers for good together and
like just really take over this world
that's what i've been trying to say
sharpay i've been here for you the whole
time and i just need you to like
understand a few things like god
it's about me
and right who else could it be about
you're constantly like trying to stay on
my spotlight like you're so jealous i
don't even like light just seriously
like why don't you just
sashay over there okay
thanks
we're better together than we are apart
agree
agreed okay thank you now get back to
your computer and write me a song can i
stay back over to you yeah yeah thanks
queen i feel like ryan like would
probably end up going to juilliard like
become successful as like a producer
songwriter composer
and like end up like a judge on like
rupaul's drag race like no and like ryan
would always be trying to like help
sharpay like you know i'm doing this new
show like come in okay could only get
you the part of you know
stagehand right like the roles reversed
when ryan's on top he's gracious that's
actually so true that's how it would go
that's how life goes it's literally what
happened to baby jane you ever see that
movie no
i never finished it but basically like a
baby jane
that's like a whole thing but all right
i'll tell you so baby jane was like this
movie star when she was a baby and like
the parents were obsessed with baby
james baby jane had a sister and like
they didn't care about the sister
because baby jane was like making all
this money the sister became like evil
because her parents were so [ __ ] mean
to her and they didn't care about her
because she wasn't baby jane so when
they grew up also then baby james was in
an accident like everything was over for
her and i'm pretty sure i never finished
the movie but i'm pretty sure the sister
was behind it so when they grow up baby
jane is in a wheelchair they're like old
women now living in a house together off
of baby jane's money but the evil sister
who became evil because her parents were
so mean to her like she like locks her
in
like a a cabinet you know like she's so
mean to her she locks her in her room
talks from the attic
so and she's in a wheelchair so she
can't help herself and she's just like
waiting for her mean older sister to
come she was like when baby jane was on
top she was very nice to her sister but
when then baby jane was on bottom and
the other [ __ ] was on top she was evil
oh sounds like the kitchen front does it
i was thinking that too that's the book
for the red one that we are recording
the new episode of the redheads tonight
so if you try to along with us yes email
the redheadsbookclub gmail.com with your
questions snitch and i just finished the
kitchen front by jennifer ryan is a
historical fiction book with a lot of
strong female characters and i have a
lot to say about the books so
i want to save my opinions
now
sharpay we're working
sorry my social media is just popping
off i just hit a thousand followers how
sad for you
gabriella has a million
ryan you're being like a [ __ ]
i'm just trying to keep things in
perspective sharpie what's the fifth
story [ __ ] real housewives beverly
hills chargery kemsley says she's
feeling blessed for her family's safety
after the home invasion darite is
speaking out she took to instagram and
posted a statement on saturday saying as
you all know by now i've been through a
terrifying ordeal one that no parent or
person should ever have to experience
i've received so many messages of love
and support and i thank you all from the
bottom of my heart it's truly
overwhelming she said my kids are
unaware of what happened they slept
through it and i thank god for keeping
my kids and myself from being physically
harmed but that she's just trying to get
back to normal life for her right
because her kids don't know that
something major happens something major
traumatic happening so like even the
rest of the weekend they dressed up for
halloween good i think they're back to
filming real housewives of beverly hills
just like in that tick tock you sent me
there was a meal a dinner yeah that they
all got together for so i think dariet's
just like throwing herself back into
normal life mostly probably for her kids
and also to move on from it
so i'm just
i think that's probably the best thing
to do like you don't want to spook the
kids
um but i will say like and i don't know
why it's bothering me so much like
people who are just like doubting that
she went through this and saying it's an
insurance scam or it's a story line um
i think they see her getting back to
life so quickly and they're like look
she's not even traumatized but when you
have kids and like you go through
something traumatic even if you don't
have kids like you just have to get up
and like keep going so like that's what
you do that's what you do in life but
especially for kids if they they really
don't know they really didn't know like
she's not going to be the one to shake
things up i know what that's really a
blessing like for real that they didn't
even wake up like it's amazing yeah and
i'm sure she's
would prefer it that way i'm sure she'd
prefer it didn't happen at all but you
know what i mean yeah i agree so glad to
hear from her and to hear that the
family is doing as well as possible yeah
i'm
i'm a team to read on this and i really
will not tolerate any slander like
doubting people's trauma it really
bothers me i would agree with you
sharpay girl
finally
you have my back
chef hey you're like gaslighting me no
you were like so [ __ ] phony to my
face and then like you run around with
troy gabriella chad zeke yesterday
literally like you were the one [ __ ]
gaslighting me at least i own who i am
like yes i'm a [ __ ] i'm a star i am
that [ __ ] and you like run around being
like oh my god i'm just like the poor
little victim little composer boy like
me and kelsey we're the victims but
you're not because you're nice to my
[ __ ] face and then you betray me you
betray your own sister
well sharpay if you really want to go
there after years of being knocked down
by you told i'm not good enough that
i'll never ever be more than a stage
never happened i'm starting to find my
voice sharpay good for you sure you
don't like how it sounds no i think it's
fine i'm gonna sing to my own tune girly
girl no we think that's great ryan
seriously you can take your new attitude
and shove it right up your hairy ass
makes me feel like ryan's ass is like so
pristine
totally it's not harry at all he's like
a very maintained person yeah his nails
are always done yeah
he doesn't let it slip no i mean he
would have his pants hemmed but
that's just ryan yeah ryan tings ryan
tings okay let's dive into the tv recap
segment which is brought to you by
betterhelp
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals we'll better help
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist where you can start
communicating in under 48 hours it's not
a crisis line it is professional therapy
and it's all done securely online how it
works is that you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your therapist and in return you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room again
betterhelp is completely committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
that make it easy and free to change
therapists if needed it's more
affordable than offline therapy and they
also offer financial aid
so many people have been using
betterhelp they are recruiting an
additional therapist in all 50 states
and we have a special offer for the
morning chose listeners get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com toast
again that's 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
toast
um i was just going to say something
margaret is this like the first episode
of the morning toast you've like
listened to in full in like years yeah i
was thinking about that like when you
did the final countdown song i obviously
know about it because you guys like post
about it and people you've never heard
of it but i've never really no well what
do you guys post the clips on instagram
i always watch those you should do that
more
and we're getting in trouble from star
wars yeah like but so what do you think
now that you're sitting here like
listening to the show live like what do
you think no i think it's hilarious i've
never not it's just not hilarious
yeah we have a web show too
that's true when i do listen and i watch
me too
we talked about that yesterday yeah this
podcast episode we did yesterday was
actually like just a really fabulous
episode it was [ __ ] hysterical we
were doing general q a so we took some
questions but we mostly were just like
couldn't shut the [ __ ] up the whole time
that's so cool you're talking about you
know
i wanted to ask you a question that we
were asked yes it's the best question
okay
what's the most embarrassing part about
being an influencer
i'll tell you what we said and then um
then maybe that'll inspire but for me
it's like when you go to an event and
like you're working like you're there to
like take pictures but like wait a
minute i never like travel with like an
assistant or a photographer or anyone
really and usually i'm just like going
to work and so like having to get
someone there to like take a picture of
me
or it's like maybe i would bring zach
but i don't want him to even like see me
in that situation you know and like see
me at a low and like when he needs to
take pictures of me in public like it's
so embarrassing and he doesn't do
anything to make me feel more
comfortable yeah like do this or like
that looks great like he's just like
you're not gonna feel worse he's like
you're not gonna like that's mean so um
i would say that's like the most
embarrassing we cited a few hysterical
examples yeah what's your least or like
least favorite thing most embarrassing
thing um about the influence or
lifestyle the most embarrassing thing
like when you go on your influencer play
dates or like you go to so many like
influencers just like tings but it's
like that's not bad because we're all in
the same coach like everyone's taking
photos for each other sort of thing and
they're all good at taking photos no
exactly i think it's like
that's a good one but also like i find
like the just like even though i do it
all the time so it's shocking like
storying like in the back of an uber or
like speaking like in you know what i
mean like yeah like fully in public like
that's really hard like when i do my
weather reports and everyone's just like
that's rough no that's painful yeah it's
painful probably but you do it for the
craft yeah of course and it's become
really the highlight of my day it's the
first thing i watch yeah so many people
tell me that they don't even check the
weather app i don't you are the weather
app you should launch a weather app yeah
and it's just like then like i got to
just like telling people what to wear
like you could tell me at 60 degrees i'm
like okay what does that mean pants or
shorts right what kind of coat right
at all
it's for pre-season mm-hmm
yeah yeah
um okay tv recap the potomac finale was
on last night and honestly it was so
stupid everyone's acting like a child um
we got to see karen's 25th wedding
anniversary party it was so nice and
everyone kept making a big deal of the
stairs because they just cannot leave
karen alone um but the event seemed
really pretty i think it was really cool
that macy gray was there and i have to
assume that they've been friends for
four years like macy gray watched the
show and that's how they met right yeah
like she got they became friends like
once karen became you know household
queen um the whole thing was just like
so odd to me i feel like typically when
they do vower neurals it's like on bravo
shows you know they go to a hotel it's
like a whole weekend and there's like
all these things like it was just like
thrown at the end of the episode it was
seriously like in like a staged like
production room and it was anybody
else's event like we would be
roasting it yeah ripping it to shreds
but because it was karen it was gorgeous
it was it was really it was honestly the
most stunning event i've ever seen my
favorite part was that like that the
outside of the building like it was just
assuming and then you walked into this
most beautiful affair agreed percent has
like just so many friends in her life it
was a real event like there were people
there who are really celebrating their
bower new role and karen's sister looks
just like her it's crazy yeah i couldn't
stop thinking that so it was but the
whole it was just a weird way to end the
season yeah like off the backs of this
fight between the men like no one even
cares we haven't even spoken about the
fight between chris and michael from
last season like nobody cares yeah and i
didn't realize everyone was waiting for
michael darby to show up all season and
he's me neither and when mia said like
he exists it's like no that's not like a
thing a thing about michael darby like
he's so elusive it's like no he actually
needs to make himself scarce because
every time he shows up he's getting
ourselves into trouble no 100
and i thought the fight between
the boys was so stupid and then when
candice got involved it's just like it
wasn't even it was so a conversation not
worth having like they don't need to
work it out of course michael and chris
are not going to be friends literally
candace called his wife who just had a
baby wide like why would why wouldn't
it's not even the worst thing she's ever
no of course not like why would michael
be friends with chris and
candace for one [ __ ] second like yeah
why are we trying to make this
friendship happen it's not meant to
happen yeah
it was and suddenly juan is like so
invested in anything when he can't even
like he's only more invested in the
fight between michael and chris than he
is with like anything going on in his
own personal life no i agree and i just
really love michael and juan's
friendship i really do
it's hysterical i think it's really cute
and it's cute how they went on the
double date and i just it's
it's something unexpected yeah and i
think with that whole robin and juan
thing i think like
i i mean because i'm thinking like why
is he like being such a baby about
her
talking about this and i don't think
that he's necessarily mad that she's
talking about her then she's he's mad
that she's talking about it on camera
yeah and it's just like this narrative
again that like he's like a deadbeat dad
yeah and which is all true like he
wasn't a good partner when they were
first married but like and that's why
they divorced and it's either tabula
rasa or it's not yeah no and i think
that's probably what what a therapist
would say to them i was thinking like of
course like it's clear robin has like
trauma from the time that they were like
so as she should but then like
right this is a nice
place please don't put your feet on the
couch
ryan you're pregnant yes everyone it's
kelsey's
never telling
it's troyes
no
i
like i understand if robin is still
upset about those things but then she
shouldn't be remarrying juan like then
she should they still have things to
work through you should table harass it
with someone else 100 you know but if
you're going to be with this man and
you're going to marry him again you have
to get old and you have to be thinking
about starting like with a new baby like
you they have to work some [ __ ] out yeah
no they can't be bringing in this old
stuff you know giselle has really cooled
the jets on karen hugher even though she
did drop like a bomb yesterday
saying like that's why karen's always
damning people because her and ray are
just friends
do you remember that she said that on
the show yeah in her commentary because
the guy who was doing the um ceremony
was basically like friendship friendship
friendship friendship and giselle in her
commentary was like this guy's talking a
lot about friendship maybe like is that
why gisele is i mean is that why karen
is constantly dming people like because
her and wright are just friends um
i obviously wasn't paying attention
and
that like
if karen if karen and ray after how many
years of marriage 25 years of marriage
are at a place where they're like just
friends and maybe they got a little
something on the side like and it works
for them yeah then it works for them
that it works for them then it works for
me all in all it was like not this
climax there was really no nothing there
yeah i agree that's the whole season
just like fizzled out yeah but the
reunion does look really good the
reunion looks so good first of all they
all look amazing they were all inspired
by you sharpay literally
pink queens they look beautiful nicki
minaj is there i'm so excited i can't
believe it and it really feels like it's
going to be a great reunion and you know
what when you look at the production
value the budget the set of that reunion
versus the beverly hills one
why are they so different well no just
the size of the couch yeah someone but
also the grand like the opulence it
really feels like there's a completely
different level of beverly hills and
potomac like just comparing the reunions
oh i didn't get that vibe i just think
someone like mismeasured the couch and
that's all there is the couch i also
think like the outfits like they all
when you saw them from the side they all
have like trains going down like i don't
know i just feel like it's it looks way
better yeah
i think there's just like and there's
like they're all on beverly hills like
wearing different [ __ ] like well usually
there's a color
yeah but i feel like you can't tell the
wheelhouse of beverly hills like to all
the same there's like i guess in potomac
it was white it was yellow like they
always get a color i think it looks
great and i think it works for them and
you need that structure yeah maybe but i
don't think you're right you can tell
the beverly hills housewives what to
wear and you but they do all look like a
michigan like no and they
the looks aren't great and actually andy
asked someone oh when taysha was on
watch what happens live he was like
who's your favorite best dress for a
real housewives beverly hills he was
like the fans are like not feeling the
looks and that when i like reflected i
was like
yeah think about the dress that erica
jane is wearing to this reunion like
literally a tiny little pink short mini
dress then look at literally any of the
women from potomac they're literally
wearing gowns with trains like you would
wear it to like a royal wedding yeah how
are these two the same
i mean they're not
they're not
so i don't even i think my best dress
though probably for beverly hills would
be lisa renna because i thought that her
outfit was interesting and cool yeah no
i can't so who's your best dressed i
don't know i don't even remember what
literally any of them are wearing
i'll watch again tonight maybe garcelle
and actually her dress was like a little
mother of the bride yeah yeah i have to
look i don't remember but i oh something
looks cute they all look cute they look
like they're going out to dinner they
all get so dressed up for a night out in
uh beverly hills for a dinner we're
dressed up in the reunion yeah like when
they all showed up to retest that first
party because she did like a black tie
party that's what they all should be
wearing to the reunion yeah and i just
like we'll never get over that wasted
gucci outfit that during war in palm
springs like just for dinner in the
house like head to toe gucci like tights
all like sparkle sequins like she should
be wearing that as a reunion 100
okay let's talk about real housewives of
salt lake city also boring um there was
like that really okay so the thing is is
like i'm really growing
lisa is really growing on me
but then she does things that like take
10 steps backwards because i really do
feel like a lot of the women are
misunderstanding her like i think that
that fight with in the limo with mary
was not her fault like mary was just on
one because
then jenny she was even like when she
first said it it was uh it
heather brought it up like it warms your
ovaries she's like she was testing
correcting heather first and then with
lisa mary was like i usually really like
mary i i just felt like she was 100
wrong she woke up on the wrong side of
the bed woke up on the wrong side of the
bed and i can move on from that but like
i don't we don't need to go into the
depths of googling no and you know what
when it comes to the catering thing like
i don't think lisa was responsible and i
think when she said like i would never
get in the way of like an lgbtq event
like i actually really believed her like
me too so i'm like you know what i think
this [ __ ] is misunderstood i think
people think she's calculated but she's
actually like not but then she goes and
pulls that [ __ ] where she invited that
guy from mary's church obviously to go
talk to meredith he was being an amazing
actor the whole thing was set up and so
it's like well is lisa this like
manipulative calculating you know
chess player or is she not yeah i didn't
understand that event so the way that i
was feeling in last night's episode is
like lisa does a lot of things that you
know she's playing chess and she's
probably not right in every situation
but i'm just like really digging her
right now i can't there's no rhyme or
reason i agree and especially like and
last season i was like all about whitney
and heather and even the flashback to
lisa saying like your wardrobe is like a
little utah like you could step it up
yeah no it was mean and that's really
how they got off on the wrong foot and
and so i understand my last season like
i was just not here for lisa and i also
misunderstood her i thought lisa was
like
so when i was watching the show i
thought she was like kind of shy because
of the tone of her voice like i thought
she was like quieter but then then we
saw her watch what happened side and she
seemed really thirsty so i was like okay
so everything that she does on the show
is is performative is performative but
now i'm understanding her better and
it's like no she's not shy nor
exceedingly thirsty she just is who she
is and she's just not apologizing for
for that and she's a little [ __ ] i
think the vibe that i got from her the
first season was that like she was in
like a different social group than all
the women and she was in like a cooler
group like she hangs with rach parcell
and i think that she like looked down on
that's how i felt i felt like she was
looking down on the woman from a social
perspective i felt like in the first
season she was like trying to be like so
coy about everything you know like she's
too cool
like meredith's like you know sidekick
friend who's also going to stab you like
and so i didn't understand her and now
that i feel like i do understand her and
i feel like the reunion helped me
understand her more where it's like no
she's not desperate to like be loved by
everyone otherwise she would have
apologized for everything and moved on
and just switched gears and been like oh
that didn't work let me try something
else right so now that i get her a
little bit more and i felt like i did
like her approach to whitney just being
like let's [ __ ] move forward yeah i
mean we could go yeah i could apologize
for all the times i said you had bad
style and you weren't that cool or
anything right
um or we could just start a new and i
feel like whitney and her confessionals
like she can't she's shady she's
obsessed with lisa like obsessed and
also like lisa i'm sorry she is so
fabulous i know like every time it's
hard to dislike her like when she's
going to wendy's when she's showing up
with these looks like every time she
steps out of the car she's just like
she's
incredible and you know what it's not
like
everything she wears is so interesting
like roller skating with that lipstick
on yeah and it's just there's two sides
yeah and i'm not using that lipstick no
i know i agree and you know what i do
feel like they're taking a really long
time to get to this gen chat thing
because i think next week they get on
the bus but i don't think it really
happens till the week after it's gonna
yeah but i'm so glad the bus is next
week like i took enough around i'm ready
i forgot that that's what's waiting for
us so i am very excited that the ball is
moving in that direction and also and
that lisa is already starting to like
dislike jen but why didn't she invite
jen to fresh wolf she invited anyone who
like supported fresh wolf yeah and jen
literally showed up to the photo show
photo shoot yes yeah with wolves i don't
know i think lisa's line of thinking was
that like jen was mad at her for
bringing up the guy who recorded her
and she didn't want to like
have jen honestly like even if i was
friends with jenna i would never invite
her to something that my kids like were
like passionate about she ruins
everything like she throws glasses like
she's not really a well-behaved person
yeah but you know what in the last few
episodes and i mean like obviously i'll
be eating i know it's next week and last
year she's been bothering me really
reforms
i know and you know like even um next
week they
she's going at it with someone she's
like how many times i have to apologize
and you know what i'm like yeah like she
really has yeah like um obviously when
it comes to down to the you know the
fraud i'm completely not it all starts
fresh but i'm watching it like
in real time yeah and it's like she's
actually acting quite
normal yeah
so yeah both episodes last night were
not like great housewives it was like
kind of boring yeah but i know we're in
for it with salt lake city so i'm fine
to wait and i just like love i just love
the franchise the looks like them tubing
like what a fun day i mean angie
i know everything
she looks so great she looks so great
like i just imagine literally having to
have a whole wardrobe like and you use
it quite frequently i feel like you ski
like many times
like
yeah it's yeah they're like they want to
go hang out catch up like they go skiing
yeah it's crazy
when they sit on the side of a mountain
like and have a drink it's so fun yeah
how do the cameras like do that i don't
know cameras like ski with them yeah
they do that's crazy it must be fun for
the camera i'm sure they like every you
know in any show like most people like
half the people could probably ski yeah
so they're like let's do it maybe they
should like go pros or some [ __ ] yeah
they definitely have like both
um
so yeah
tomorrow we will recap succession yes
because we didn't want to watch it last
night like there was so many houses and
we want to enjoy it yes i want to take
my time i didn't want to be like up late
like speeding through it yeah exactly
and same with curb i'll actually watch
curb it was so bad
and i'm actually was thinking like i
wanted to talk about like how
disappointed i am oh wow because
literally i don't think there's
essentially curb is like a very
it's like a dry humor show that's really
at the end of the day like a commentary
on social
interactions the culture the zeitgeist
like it's really like a a really
interesting commentary on like the way
we live and
to think that the way
we've been living for the last 18 months
is not even addressed in the show
it's so disappointing and i never
thought i'd say that i [ __ ] hate when
people talk about clothing
but it's hilarious no but last before
covey curb ended like series finale and
then larry said he was bringing it back
in covet he said he was bringing it back
because like what did you talk about
because it's like larry and kobe like
larry probably hates wearing masks yeah
so
i agree with you i mean i'll i haven't
seen that it's not funny no literally
nothing happened there's no coat vid
like
there's nothing
still with the stupid netflix show
oh yeah
okay
um
so yeah that's our show well really my
show it's the sharpay show thank you all
so much for coming to my show and ryan
you know thank you for being here you're
welcome i mean i just love to support
you and also under cut you and back and
manipulate me yeah yep and gaslight me
yeah i'm the real victim here that too
yeah um i think we should lead them out
with the song sharpay what do you think
yes but before we do darbys thank you so
much for being here we know how busy you
are just putting on the spring musical
music how running the theater you
thought our little show was something no
it's something what do you get
what do you give our production value
over here production value is better
than mine
better one better than mine of course i
don't know that hsm three set was
something well that's when we had real
like movie theater budget yeah but on
october 24th 2008 yeah
what sho should songs should we uh well
you could go out with one of yours you
know
fabulous that's a great song that you
wrote that i wrote yes wrote for you
how does this start
um
[Music]
ice cream okay you're tweaking
or the other one
the one from broadway don't you want it
can't you see it imagine
imagine having everything we ever
dreamed don't you want it yeah maybe
maybe can't you see it kinda imagine
first audition after college i get the
lead
apart from me well of course you gotta
believe it
you and i all the fame sharpay what's
his name sounds exciting inviting let's
do it then
that's all i know guys thank you so much
we hope you enjoyed halloween toast to
win 2021 we'll be back next year with
halloween 2022 but until then we'll see
you tomorrow we love you guys thank you
so much for sending to the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so
are you taking it
off if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe or give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found set spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i heart radio cast box all
the places swear we listen to podcast
find out morning chelsea five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are have an amazing day and if
you're still here want to go drop an
emoji on our most recent instagram how
about just the star emoji for two well
one and a half stars thank you guys
drop as many stars as you see on these
couches one two or three that's a really
really good one um love you guys we'll
see you tomorrow bye